hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt ich möchte heute ein ganz einfaches
rezept machen und zwar gibt es heute
kleine pc stückchen also mehr ringe und
zwar möchte ich dir heute schön bunt
machen und später auch noch dekorieren
und zwar mache ich jetzt in ein paar
tagen eine kleine baby shower party und
dafür fertig drehen rosa ein denn ihr
wir erwarten ja eine tochter aber ich
zeige euch auch noch so kleine blaue
bunte menge stückchen und bisher
stückchen und die werden eben später mit
ein paar zucker streuseln dekorieren und
die kam eben super vorbereiten und kann
es einfach so als deko hinstellen oder
auch einfach so als kleinen zweck und
die dann einfach schön naschen und ich
zeige ich jetzt einfach mal die zutaten
ich nehme jetzt hier zwei weise 100
gramm zucker eine prise salz und ein
teelöffel speisestärke und die habe ich
noch lebensmittelfarben und zwar in rosa
und in blau und normalerweise hat man
immer pro weiß immer 50 gramm zucker
aber da ich heute jetzt etwas größere
weiße habe und zwar in größe l habe ich
jetzt auch ein bisschen mehr zucker
genommen also wenn ihr das eben
abschätzen könnt also erst steht hier
auf der verpackung jemand drauf wie groß
die eier sind und wenn ja in größe m
habt stimmt mit den 100 gramm also vor
150 gramm
und wenn die eier etwas größte nimm dir
einfach ein bisschen mehr zug und das
geht ganz einfach und zwar nimmt dir
jetzt das eiweiß oder die eiweiße und
gibt etwas salz rein dazu eine prise
und schlag des oder höher führt das
erste mal statt
und bevor dass es dabei ganz steif ist
gebe ich schon mal den zucker mit rein
zu machen und damit im komplett streit
geschlagen
die
jetzt lass dich der frei höchster stufe
so etwa drei bis vier minuten lang
rühren denn dann löst sich der zucker
auf und man darf man zwischen den
fingern wenn man da eben kurz mit den
fingern reingeht dem keine zuckerstücke
mehr fühlen
deswegen lassen wir sie einfach auf
höchster stufe durch wählen
sieht schön aus gern mit schnee
und jetzt kann ich die speisestärke
unterheben die muss jetzt vorher aber
durch gesiebt werden jetzt rein und die
muss man eben unterheben also das geht
dann ganz einfach mit dem teig schaber
hatte ich hab es kurz unter und jetzt
könnt ihr das in jeder beliebigen farbe
einfärben und weil ich es heute zwei
farben machen möchte teile ich das jetzt
zwei portionen
und zum einfärben nehme ich jetzt diese
lebensmittel verpassten also flüssige
farben würde ich nicht empfehlen weil
dann einfach die konsistenz zu sehr
verändert wird und am besten eignet sich
lebensmittel verpassen
aber ganz ganz ganz wenig
und ich habe mir zwei spritzbeutel
bereits vorbereitet ich nehme es ein weg
spritzbeutel und hab dann ein loch thüle
treffen die zeit nicht euch auch gleich
und ich hab das jetzt ganz wenig nur ein
gefährt weil ich eben so pastelltöne
erhalten möchte deswegen helle hose und
ein helles hellblau
und jetzt kann ich hier so kleine
beethoven spritzen
also wie gesagt hier mit dieser
machtfülle
hin
und jetzt werden sie im vorgeheizten
backofen bei 70 grad umluft für ungefähr
70 bis 90 minuten getrocknet also ich
werde sie schon mal nach einer stunde
kontrollieren wenn man sie nämlich
bewegen kann sind sie trocken also wenn
sie nicht mehr kleben und dann zeige ich
euch liebe sie weiter dekorieren
die pc stücke sind schön getrocknet und
ich werde jetzt noch fertig dekorieren
und dafür brauchen wir jetzt eigentlich
nur zwei zutaten und zwar etwas weiße
schokolade
da können die schokolade oder kuvertüre
leben das ist egal und zucker sträuße
und ich nehme jetzt die in rosa rein mal
in blau die schokolade habe ich jetzt
schon fein gehackten muss jetzt
schmelzen
ihr könnt es jetzt entweder im wasserbad
auf dem herd machen oder so wie ich ihn
kenne wird das mache ich jetzt weil es
einfach praktisch ist
ich kann nämlich die maschine hier auf
30 grad einstellen und dann schmilzt es
einfach vor sich hin ohne dass es eben
zu heiß wird also dafür ist die maschine
hat echt super geeignet
aber ihr könnt wie gesagt dass auf dem
wasserbad machen
ich hab da auch schon mehrere videos
dazu gemacht vielleicht weiß einer von
euch auch in welchem video dann könnt
ihr mir das gerne in die kommentare
schreiben
aber ich werde diese methode im
wasserbad auch gerne mal als cache basic
machen und ich stelle das jetzt hier
einfach auf stufe 3
das ist die intervall stufe 3 die rührt
dann einfach gelegentlich
die
ich will jetzt die geschmolzene
schokolade um damit ihr gleich seht was
ich mache deswegen fühle ich die hier in
so ein kleines schildchen rein
jetzt nehme ich immer so mbc stück und
tunkt es hier so ein bisschen in die
schokolade so dass es auch an den
rändern bisschen sichtbar ist
den überschuss streife jetzt mal ab und
dann wird es auch direkt in die streusel
getan
und so könnte es dann hier auf dem
abkühlen gitter einfach trocknen lassen
die pc stückchen sind jetzt getrocknet
ich hatte sie nämlich für etwa eine
halbe stunde im kühlschrank und könnte
es ja auch direkt servieren also ich
habs jetzt hier einfach mal getrennt
angerichtet blauen rosa aber ich finde
diese pc stücke auch zb auf hochzeiten
ganz schön an so einer candybar wenn ihr
sowas habt oder wenn ihr eben jemanden
kennt könnte das gerne als dessert
zubereiten
entweder kann so pur essen so als
kleinen snack oder man kann sie zum
beispiel auch auf desserts draufsetzen
also wie zum beispiel auf sahne desserts
mit ein paar himbeeren und dann eben so
dass der pc stückchen mit drauf finde
ich auch ganz lecker wir haben ein
problem was für ein problem stoff so
beschrieben ist schon ein problem
ja aber das muss mein pc video sagen
sagt jetzt wahrscheinlich weil ich die
ganzen streupflicht auf dem boden
verteilt habe
samir naja auf jeden fall hoffe ich dass
ich dieses rezept gefallen hat ihr könnt
die natürlich auch sowie sanierer
vorgeschlagen hat als regenbogen mehr
ringe machen oder regen baiser stückchen
finde ich auch ganz hübsch und falls ich
sie nach macht freue ich mich wenn ich
mir fotos auf instagram und facebook
schickt und das rezept könnt ihr nochmal
nachlesen auf 6 - blog.de
bis zum nächsten mal 5 jetzt könnte aber
auch tschüss sagen